at the main interchange of bakmut a
reminder that the roads here are not
safe
bombed buildings empty streets and no
power
those who remain have little food Anya
can't afford to leave and says she only
stays so she can take care of her dogs
she feels abandoned
people under the rubble were screaming
for help for five days nobody needs us
never before not even now that's the
truth
few people remain here the rubbish is
piling up and the playground's a
wonderful of children are now empty for
most it's too dangerous to be outside
and to escape the shells and Rockets
they live underground
where we live
the hardships she's happy to be with her
granddaughter others are angry Sergey
doesn't blame the Russians but his own
government
I can't understand why they can't give
us electricity in Donetsk it's eight
years of war and they have electricity
he doesn't say he is pro-russian but he
doesn't link the Russian invasion and
his living conditions
shops are closed after being damaged by
selling and people are angry
at this Market people shout at us to
leave others say they will have a shot
they blame reports by journalists for
enabling attacks by Russian forces
for those that remain here the situation
has really deteriorated over the last
few months this town continues to be a
battlefield with Ukrainian forces still
holding onto it but through the Russians
not far out